[Música]
la lencería es moda o no
en la alta costura como aquí en
sí se convierte en ropa la ropa interior
ya no necesita un top
[Música]
Qué debe mostrarse y qué debe ocultarse
Esta es la cuestión existencial que
siempre ha agitado el mundo de la moda
la lencería porque revela más de lo que
cubre juega con los códigos de la
seducción clásica como aquí con esta
colaboración entre la marca francesa
livi y el cabaret parisino Crazy horse
pero hoy en día las limitaciones del
glamour tienen que hacer frente a un
nuevo deseo la comodidad
la verdadera tendencia es volver a los
calzones altos y las tangas altas
esto es bastante nuevo como se explica
esta nueva tendencia queremos hacerlo de
hecho queremos que nos sostengan lo
suficiente y estar menos constreñidas al
menos en la zona del pero en la zona de
los glúteos quiero absolutamente ser
sostenida y Mostrar mi ropa interior
como un compromiso real de hecho un
compromiso con lo que compramos un
compromiso para dar sentido a nuestras
compras y a nuestro poder adquisitivo
Así que hoy rimar a los sexy con lo
cómodo Esta es la primera directriz de
una mujer quiere sentirse cómoda con la
lencería todo el día y toda la noche en
segundo lugar es la deseabilidad
Entonces qué se puede hacer para volver
compatible los principios de seducción y
Confort
está propiciado una evolución de los
tejidos utilizados para la lencería
notamos en particular el encaje lives
que ha integrado la elasticidad en su
vida
nuevos materiales que no solo atraerán a
las mujeres otro mercado está creciendo
rápidamente
los hombres
por supuesto todo esto está ligado al
fenómeno obviamente del género estamos
en proceso de redibujar de redefinir y
de empujar los límites del género y está
muy bien porque permite a los hombres
liberarse de los estereotipos demasiado
masculinos y también dejarles el campo
libre para interesarse por el material
para querer tener una actividad
interesante con sus productos hoy en día
también quieren tener estilo Porque con
todos estos movimientos toda esta
comunicación en las redes sociales ellos
también quieren una imagen quieren un
cierto esteticismo y quieren agradar y
seducir y creo que es muy bonito decir
los invitamos al universo femenino y a
ustedes mujeres tengan la mente abierta
interesense también por el vestuario de
sus chicos interesense por todo ese tipo
de artículos Y eso obviamente va Unido
al desarrollo de marcas y productos
Cómo funciona la noción de sexy para los
humanos
estamos acostumbrados a tener ropa
interior masculina relativamente sobria
con materiales que no son transparentes
por ejemplo con algodón modal materiales
que son relativamente opacos y la
verdadera novedad Es que hoy vamos a
trabajar con encajes y bordados en ropa
interior masculina Así que tendremos
transparencia vamos a tener un nuevo
alcance algo muy diferente de lo que
estamos acostumbrados a ver y esa es la
verdadera novedad para el hombre sin
embargo en términos de comunicación la
lencería masculina sigue por desgracia
luchando por desarrollarse como su
hermana mayor femenina que continúa
jugando con la erotización del cuerpo
porque es tan importante este partido
porque según Pascal Pick antropólogo eco
learch la erotización del cuerpo permite
suscitar el deseo del otro pero también
estabilizar una relación consentida y
exclusiva con el fin de construir un
vínculo sensual y afectivo sin embargo a
principios de la de 2000 la marca
canadiense de lencería fortnite intentó
cambiar este concepto de cosificación de
los cuerpos jugando con una mirada
estrafalaria imagina que la lencería no
solo es sexy también puede salvar vidas
el erotismo al servicio de los primeros
auxilios Aunque la marca fortnite ya no
existe se crean otras nuevas a un ritmo
frenético un ejemplo recién ha sido en
Londres de underweis que puede
traducirse a español como ropa interior
de día nació principalmente de nuestra
insatisfacción personal con la industria
estábamos convencidos de que existía una
Clara brecha en el mercado en términos
de que las mujeres sólo podían elegir
entre ropa interior muy aburrida o
hipersexualizada
realmente estamos intentando cambiar la
percepción de estos criterios y
conseguir que las mujeres esperen más
exijan más y obtengan mucho más de lo
que han tenido nunca
yo soy natury diseñadora de moda
filipino estadounidense que lleva 45
años en el negocio y la lencería está de
acuerdo cuando empecé era muy vulgar o
muy anticuado
tradicional para mí la lencería
realmente moda y para mí sentirme bien
por dentro es fundamental
es imprescindible y realmente creo que
puede sentirte bien por dentro pero
también estar cómodo
mis respuestas que nunca hay que
sacrificar la comodidad por la belleza
y por eso estoy muy orgullosa de nuestra
lencería natori porque es glamurosa
cómoda y glamurosa
lo uno no tiene porque sustituir a lo
otro Eso no se negocia
la lencería una historia de la moda una
historia del cuerpo una historia de la
emancipación
[Música]